c'est en écoutant en fait son histoire
via un podcast des pistes sur terre là
l'émission de france culture et j'ai dû
en entendre parler de leur histoire en
2016 et je me suis rendu compte que bien
avant baceux 2001 2002 2003 en fait leur
histoire elle avait défrayé la chronique
pascal eu assez peu de détenus français
à guantanamo donc ils font partie des
ses plus six ou sept quelque chose comme
ça et donc c'est vrai qu'à l'époque on a
beaucoup parlé d'eux puis après
l'histoire et est tombé un petit peu
dans l'oubli est revenu sur le devant de
la scène un peu je dirai au moment de de
la guerre en syrie où le moment où il
avait attiré 2 redevenu une terre de
jihad et c'est vrai qu'on a pas mal
sollicité mourad et nizar pour raconter
leur histoire et dissuader à des jeunes
de de faire ces mêmes erreurs en fait on
a quelques planches 1 du livre qui
défilent en arrière-plan donc vénissieux
landre jalalabad nous sommes au pakistan
le tout à travers un réseau qui fournit
contact logement faux papiers et vous ne
comprenez pas la finalité de tout cela
et finalement vous direz que vous avez
compris que l'émir vous l'a fait à
l'envers
disons que je me rends compte au fur et
à mesure de ce voyage que j'intègre que
j'ai intégré en tout cas à un réseau en
effet qui est destiné à embrigader déjà
alors bien sûr moi je
je m'en rends pas compte sur le court
parce que parce que parce que je suis
pas informé suffisamment parce que je
fais confiance à ce frère qui m'a
proposé ce voyage mais en arrivant dans
ce camp d'entraînement d'al qaïda un
camp d'entraînement d'ailleurs qui ne se
limite pas à l'entraînement militaire
mais aussi un entraînement terroriste où
je comprends la réalité de l'endroit où
je me suis retrouvé embarqué et donc
c'est tout là c'est là où commence le
cauchemar et c'est là où ou où la
réalité du terrorisme intègre ma vie
pour la première fois et à un moment
donné vous
vous voyez arriver ce personnage qui à
l'époque n'est peut-être pas encore
l'ennemi public numéro 1 au niveau
international on parle d'oussama ben
laden d'ailleurs je sais pas qui c'est
au moment où je le rencontre
mes
pensées c'est une personne qui vient
apprenez les attentats suicides c'est
une personne qui a envie hein en tout
cas un discours très clair sur son
engagement terroristes et puis c'est une
personne qui annonce qu'il va frapper
les états unis
dans quelques jours donc c'est là en
effet que le que les attentats du 11
septembre vont prendre toute cette
réalité cette ampleur et et surtout en
moi c'est là que je vais faire le lien
entre lui et c'est sa tante à jérémie
dres comment est ce que on restitue
cette histoire là comment est ce qu'on
trouve le ton juste la bonne distance
pour finalement ne pas être accusé de
faire l'apologie du terrorisme d'une
forme de terrorisme
je pense qu'effectivement il en a jamais
vraiment été question parce que de toute
façon enfin en fait pour vous dire quand
j'ai entendu vu l'histoire de moore a
gelé rencontré une fois puis après je l'
ai vu aller d'un lycée à un autre pour
parler justement aux jeunes et de leur
faire effectivement comprendre bas
qu'elles avaient été ses erreurs à lui
quand il avait 18 ans parce que voilà il
avait 18 ans cette époque là et leur
montrer en fait de ben voilà ce qui lui
était arrivé comme ans avait marqué sa
vie de façon irrémédiable et est donc en
fait je me suis rendu compte que qui
mieux que des gens comme mourad ou nizar
peuvent parler d'eux de prévention doit
la radicalisation et de choses comme ça
parce que c'est vrai qu'un politique
n'importe qui va parler de ça ça va pas
avoir la même la même force mais ma
question est restée sur part de deux
mois sur la forme également est ce que
cette histoire là une manière
particulière d'être racontée sur le plan
de la forme je d'accord regarde les
dessins par exemple le choix des
couleurs qui est qui et qui a tué parce
qu'il ya plein de choses à dire il ya
aussi qu'une chose alors sur le plan de
la forme et des couleurs effectivement
alors pour ce qui est des couleurs j'ai
envie de dire tout ce qui est de
l'époque et ben effectivement c'est
plutôt dans des teintes un peu
sablonneuse on va dire un peu sable on
voit là et puis après pour tout et pour
tout ce qui est d'aujourd'hui parce que
le en fait le récit bascule entre le
présent et le passé et donc le présent
on est dans des couleurs réelles en fait
moi l'idée aussi par rapport à la forme
c'était d'avoir une certaine distance et
à dire que mourad et nizar ils
interviennent en tant que témoin en fait
du récit donc c'est vrai que je me mets
en scène aussi en les rencontrant et ce
qui permet aussi de voir à quel moment
je récolte la matière et ce qui permet
par exemple mourad on le voit intervenir
dans des lycées ce qui est en effet très
intéressant en tant que tel prochaine
question justement vous témoigner dans
des lycées depuis un certain temps
qu'elle est quel est le bilan comment
vos témoignages sont ils perçus bas il
est basé sur du réel donc c'est vrai que
ça parle plus aux jeunes que quelqu'un
qu'ils ne sont morale sur les dangers du
diodes moi je leur apporte un vécu et
j'espère qu'il est de nature à leur
faire réaliser que que ben que s'engager
dans cette voie est pas une bonne idée
je suis à un moment donné dans le livre
il ya eu une séquence où vous intervenez
dans un lycée et à un moment donné je
crois que si jérémy ds qui l'écrit on
entendrait une mouche voler plus
personne ne s'exprime on est suspendu à
à vos lèvres vous allez participer à un
café littéraire dans le cadre de ce
maghreb-orient du livre quel sera le
message
l'idée c'est de
se rappeler que cette bande dessinée
existe et qu'elle que c'est un support
intéressant pour pouvoir revenir sur ce
parcours et et partager les leçons que
nous mêmes avons tiré de cette histoire
en quoi j'ai omis grèce la bande
dessinée être mieux a raconté ce type
d'histoire vous avez écrit vous même un
récit
pourquoi la bande dessinée le format est
différent je pense que le format et
c'est pour ça que ben des gens comme moi
des leaders se sont prêtés justement au
jeu bah forcément ça rend plus
accessible ce type d'histoire en fait
forcément parce que voilà il ya les
images enfin c'est de la narration c'est
très fort c'est ça fait penser un peu
aux films aussi la bande dessinée et
donc ça c'est forcément plus accessible
après si vous me demandez pourquoi j'ai
choisi ce format là je sais faire que ça
je ne sais rien faire d'autre enfin je
sauve serait terrible je faisais un
documentaire vidéo donc effectivement la
bande dessinée c'était le format que je
pouvais faire et voilà je trouve que
effectivement la force que ça peut
donner c'est qu'effectivement on a vu
des images quoi on peut se projeter sur
des choses en quatrième de couverture
il est indiqué je ne sais pas qui parle
entre mourad et et nizar cette
expérience là je ne pourrai jamais
l'oublier j'ai dû apprendre à vivre avec
j'ai essayé de m'enfuir ça n'a pas
marché c'est vous
10h
enfin la question s'était finalement
après tout cela qu'est ce qui reste
il reste il reste beaucoup de
souffrance parce que malgré tout or au
delà de l'embrigadement djihadistes ya
eu aussi la carte de la conservation one
ma maman il ya eu guantanamo en effet et
une incarcération aussi en france et une
judiciarisation qui heureusement s'est
bien terminé pour moi en tout cas
puisque j'ai été relaxé et donc c'est
s'aider conséquence des conséquences
assez graves kaki et voilà qui ont
résulté de cette erreur de jeunesse en
fait parce que vous n'avez pas à faire
en face de vous un ancien jihadiste qui
voulaient faire la guerre à l'occident
ou je ne sais quoi c'est surtout un
jeune qui voulait plaire à son frère et
qui était extrêmement naïf et
inconscient et qui s'est laissé
embarquer dans une histoire
et pour les pour laquelle il a beaucoup
souffert dernière question quel
parallèle faites vous avec des années
plus tard des jeunes ces jeunes qui ont
voulu qu'ils ont réussi à partir pour un
pays comme la syrie par ben en fait moi
je trouve c'est ce qui est fou c'est que
en fait à l'époque
de mourad et israël à internet
n'existait quasiment pas il m'a expliqué
aussi que vénissieux en fait c'était
enfin aujourd'hui elle tramway keira qui
re re qui permet de rejoindre à lyon
donc à l'époque c'était beaucoup plus
enclavées et pourtant aujourd'hui avec
la connaissance parce que c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque ben laden personnes
connaissaient en 2001 avant le 11
septembre et pourtant c'est vrai que ce
que ce que je trouve surprenant c'est
que malgré la connaissance qu'on peut
avoir les biens internet via via
l'histoire en fait ben c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu tout ce mouvement des jeunes de
deux jeunes qui venaient des cités mais
d'ailleurs aussi et qui ont qui sont
partis voilà donc effectivement les
problèmes sont toujours là je dirais le
jour j'ai rencontré ben laden c'est le
tome 1 vous préparez un tome 2 en un
mois et demi après ce qu on peut
s'attendre j'en connais déjà la fin de
l'histoire
bah c'est la suisse est à dire que
effectivement des des témoignages des
amateurs de guantanamo il y en a pas
tant que ça puis voilà des témoignages
de deux détenus français en fête est
donc en fait c'est la suite
la suite de l'histoire si j'espère que
et en fait ça sort mi septembre voilà
merci beaucoup jérémie dres et mourad
benchellali d'être venu jusqu'à nos avec
nizar nassi vous contribuez à ce livre
le jour où j'ai rencontré ben laden
livre qui sera dédicacé aujourd'hui à
paris dans le cadre du maghreb orient
des livres salon du livre incontournable
évidemment pour vous en tous les cas
merci beaucoup c'est